أنا أستيقظ مبكرًا في أفضل الأوقات ،
الاستيقاظ مع الشمس هو جزء من حياتي ،
بعض الناس ينامون ، أستيقظ
وأخرج ،
مرحبًا ، لقد
صنعت هذا هو وعاء الحفلة الذي يبلغ 40 قدمًا
لديك حجم جميل
ولكن  حتى بالنسبة لهذا المستيقظ المبكر ، فإن
احتمالية السباحة التي يبلغ ارتفاعها 40 قدمًا
لدبلن أمر شاق
[موسيقى]
لن يكون هناك شيء من ذلك
بدلاً من ذلك سأسبح مع مجموعة
تسمى تأثير التموج لأنك
تبدو وكأنك تفعل ذلك بانتظام
كل يوم  اليوم ،
مجموعة رائعة من السكان
الذين يستيقظون مبكرًا الذين يأتون إلى هنا للقاء السباحة
والإفطار يأتي المطر أو يتألق
لماذا يطلق عليه 40 قدمًا لا
يبدو أن أحد يوافق ، ولا يهم على
أي حال الناس وهذا الانكسار
مرة أخرى أنني "  لقد أتيت
لأني أرتكب
خطأ فادحًا خطأ في آداب السلوك مع
إلقاء أحجار فرك جافة في وجهي
[ضحك]
أنت لباس ضيق
مع رداءك الجاف ، لا ، كل هذا
ضروري تمامًا ،
أعلم أنه سيكون
باردًا جدًا ،
وأنا أعلم
أنه سيكون جيدًا
مرح أعلم أنه سيكون باردًا جدًا
وأنا أعلم
أنني  سأضطر فقط إلى البقاء هناك
لأدنى قدر من الوقت لجعله لائقًا
بهؤلاء الأشخاص كل يوم ، أعني
كل يوم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
إذا واصلت التحرك ، لا يزال بإمكاني الشعور
بأصابعي وأصابع قدمي
وفي الوقت المناسب بالطبع
ركلة الإندورفين التي يكون كل هذا
أكثر دفئًا حول
الدفء هو مفهوم نسبي في هذه
الحالة
بعد بضع ثوانٍ ، يكون
الأمر أكثر متعة ،
لكن عندما تبدأ في الشعور بالوخز
في نهايات أصابعك ، أعتقد
أن هذا عادة  علامة جيدة ، إنها
آسف جدًا بالتأكيد ،
لكن الآن بالطبع أصبح الجسد دافئًا
وأنت بخير ، لقد شعرت للتو أنني
لم أكن أعتقد أنني كنت أعاني من نوبة قلبية
عندما ذهبت إلى هناك ، مرحبًا بك في دبلن ، يا
له من عظيم
طريقة رائعة لبدء اليوم ،
أعني
رائعة أن
هذه أيرلندا ومع
كرم الضيافة ، بالطبع ، أحضر شخص ما
قهوة
طازجة من كعكات الشوكولاتة المخبوزة حديثًا ،
فهذه طريقة رائعة
للتفاعل مع الضحك ، نعم ، رفع
بعضنا البعض أثناء الإغلاق ، يمكن للكثير
من الناس  لا نتقابل في
الداخل ، لذا بدأ الكثير من الناس في
الاتصال بالخارج وكان هذا
مكانًا رائعًا للناس ليأتوا واكتشف الناس
إعادة اكتشاف البحر وكان من
الرائع فعلاً إعادة
الشحن هذه هي الكلمة التي
أعتقد أننا قمنا بها  بالاستفادة من هذا في
العامين الماضيين في العامين الماضيين ،
رأينا الحاجة إلى
تعزيز رفاهنا العقلي في الواقع ، كنت
سأكون الفضل في إنقاذ حياتي
إلى درجة أن
جوناثان صاحب 40 قدمًا يمتلك  هذا
المقهى الرائع حيث يصر على أننا نستعد
لتناول
الإفطار ولن يسمح لي بالدفع ،
أفهم الآن لماذا يطلقون على
أنفسهم تأثير مضاعف
أعتقد أن تأثير التموج هو شيء إيرلندي
له جزء من تاريخنا الذي تعلم أن
الجميع موجود لدعمه
سواء كنا نمر بأوقات
عصيبة ، فأنت تعلم أن الجميع موجود
لدعم بعضهم البعض حقًا
كلمة واحدة تصف أيرلندا وقلب
الناس
هو أكبر شيء
القلب هو أكبر شيء
يريد الجميع أن
يحبه  هذا ما يحب الناس فعله
وكل شخص يبحث عن
الحب وأعتقد أن هذا ما تفعله أيرلندا
في معظم أنحاء المدينة ، بالكاد بدأ اليوم
بالنسبة لي
حيث بدأ الدم يتدفق مرة أخرى
لا يسعني الشعور بأنني استمتعت بالفعل
بالأفضل  بت
وليس حتى الساعة الثامنة صباحًا
[موسيقى]
أنت